need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was designed to help
you overcome the number one challenge
that is holding you back a lack of
belief in yourself so get ready for some
life-changing wisdom from Oprah Winfrey
to give you the confidence motivation
and belief that you need
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one focus on service and everybody has a
different talent and the reason we're
all so messed up is because you're
looking at everybody else's talent and
wishing you had some of their talent all
the energy that you spend thinking about
wishing about being jealous of envious
of anybody else is energy that you're
not only putting out it's going to come
back to you negatively but you're taking
that away from you
all your energy should be forced on what
do I have to offer what do I have to
give how can I be used in service
because dr. King's message of not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined by service and there is not a
job in here that you can do that you
don't switch the paradigm to service and
not make that job more fulfilling I
don't care what the job is if you say
I'm a singer I'm a dancer I'm an artist
I'm a teacher I'm a nurse I'm a doctor
I'm a janitor I'm a clerk of it if you
say if I look at this from how do I use
this in service to something bigger than
myself
it no longer becomes a job it becomes an
offering to the world
rule number two use every experience
this is the beauty of my life there's
not a thing that happened to me that I
don't look at it as a
teaching learning experience and so
whenever I'm going into any kind of
crisis I've said this many times before
I'm always looking for what is this here
to teach me rule number three be a great
reader and I would say reading is the
strongest signal for success in the
future that I've ever seen it is the
strongest strongest strongest I got my
first job in radio when I was 16 years
old tough because I've been in
broadcasting since I was 16 years old
but my first job I got because I was a
great reader when you are a great reader
you can articulate and speak and command
the English language in ways that other
people cannot and people think you're a
lot smarter than you are
lots of times because you're great
reader have you ever met a person who
was a great reader when they were young
who was not successful you never never
it is the absolute best foundation ever
in life rule number four fill your cup
if I leave you with nothing else it's
just know this for sure there is not one
thing that has ever happened to you
not one experience about one encounter
not one crisis not one joyful thing that
hasn't happened just to make you better
and help you rise every single thing
you're calling in whether you know it or
not when you figure out that you are
calling it in when you actually start
meditating or praying or doing or having
a spiritual practice which is the number
one thing you need if you want to be
successful in the world you need
something that gives back and nourishes
you regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up you end up tired
exhausted and don't have enough to give
to other people you end up resentful
every time somebody asked you because
your cup is empty and now they want some
of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill your cup and make
yourself whole that's your job also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 254 series it's free the links to
join are in the description below key to
success is what you believe is true for
yourself they think that success is
supposed to happen like that Adams
become so skilled so vigilant so
flat-out fantastic at what you do that
your talent cannot be dismissed rule
number 5 build trust I think in order to
actually do the stuff yes money is
important but I also think the thing
that I hold the dearest and the reason
why the noise about running for
president moved me so humbly and deeply
is because it means that you have
somewhere in the work gained the
people's trust yes you and there is
nothing more important to me than having
the trust of the people and the audience
and I I mean I recognize that it is the
audience who came every day and watched
you know from all over the world that
actions yes that helped me to be Who I
am so I think the renowned that the
standing the the ability to be trusted
and to say something but also much
listen don't play the billionaire things
small don't play the be small yeah it's
it's it's a very big deal because it
allows you to it allows you to actually
do the work so instead of saying gee I
would like to help so many people or you
should go out and help so many people
you can actually use that for yourself
and I am now at this stage of my career
thinking about how to do that more
poignant Lee and fruitfully I'm now
looking for ways that I can do that to
create a level of sustainability in with
in our communities that will go long
beyond my lifetime rule number six get
in sync with your life the first law is
the third law of motion in physics which
says for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction and we showed that
very beautifully in the color purple
when Missy Lee says to mr. everything
you even try to do to me
is already done to you that is not just
a rhetorical saying that is law that is
Newton's third law of motion in physics
which says everything that goes out is
coming back it's just like everything
that goes up is coming down may take a
long time to come down is coming down
everything that goes out is coming back
it's coming back so to answer the power
of manifestation and meditation what
meditation does is sync you up with the
source what meditation does is allows
you to literally tap into the power that
created you so that you are in alignment
with that and so when you carry that out
into the world everything that you do
comes from the center of that alignment
that's coming from the source that we
call God we call divine energy divine
intelligence whatever name you want to
give it to do we call life when you are
synched up with life life just gives to
you rule number seven set boundaries so
when I first started making money I was
one of those people who thought I got it
every time somebody asked me I got it
yeah so you go crazy you have to look
within yourself what do you want to do
that that that means family members
because you get a lot of cousins when
you get the banjo and show all of a
sudden you get could decide for yourself
and so I have you know I've given away
so much yes that people don't know
because most of the time you don't hear
about a number that I've helped so
people complain about what I did or
didn't do yeah I don't know me
mommy I do yeah I do and and I don't
have any let me get let me get one more
all of that very much in check rule
number eight be open and vulnerable the
reason why I was number one for 25 years
is cuz I figured out early on there is
no story anybody has ever heard that
somebody else hasn't experienced nothing
and I also figured out probably maybe
the first or second year that all pain
is the same that a mother in Somalia
feels the same way as a weather in
Seattle when she loses her child and the
common denominator in the human
experience is our emotions and our
feelings and the more vulnerable and
open you are willing to be with your
story the more actual understanding you
create with other people and the more
powerful you become people don't think
less of you for sharing your story they
think more of you for having the courage
to share it
rule number nine relax what would you
say to your younger self oh honey honey
honey Oh baby girl what the world has in
store for you first of all would be
relax it would be stop being afraid and
it would be everything's going to be
alright no matter what you're going to
be okay and rule number ten the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
surprise your fans this movie called
their eyes are watching God and I was an
extra in and it was a movie that Oprah
was producing and she had walked by and
I was making all the other extras laugh
and stuff I was telling jokes and she
she's like you're a very funny young
like what's your name I said my name is
Tiffany Haddish and I'm a stand-up
comedian and she said well keep me up to
keep me updated on your career right me
let me know what you got going on I love
comedy I said oh yeah it's a why we're
writer right
and I never got any with nothing and I
think it's because it was a lot of
misspellings or something cuz you're not
wasn't a good reader at that time so
definitely not a good right I see but
I'm better now
well she's she got the row back I wonder
why let's ask her why she didn't write
back
Oprah why didn't you write back
[Applause]
so this is a deal you are so so so good
now I've got a special bonus clip from
Oprah on how to aim for excellence that
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that is time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to take an action here we go
question number one how can you be more
open and vulnerable with somebody today
number two what is out of sync in your
life that you need to fix and number
three what does filling your cup looked
like for you I heard Jesse Jackson speak
when I was a kid saying that excellence
is the best deterrent to racism
excellence is the best deterrent to
sexism and so I went home and I put that
on my mirror and that really became my
motto so that in the third grade I was
one of those kids that made all the kids
sick because I was the first one to turn
in the book report and I was the you
know read the most books
if you want more oprah winfrey check at
the top 50 rules video i made on her the
link is right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
i'll see you there the way through the
challenge is to get still and ask
yourself what is the next right move